i'd like to welcome you to my
presentation
today i'll be speaking about the
engineering and implementation
of dityrosine bonds in order to
stabilize
viral fusion proteins for their use as
subhuman vaccines
my name is mark yandola i'm the vice
president for research and development
at calder biosciences
and i've been working for a little more
than seven years on this technology
as a member of culture biosciences
so although their localization to the
surface of the virus particle
and their critical role in the viral
life cycle makes them attractive
targets for subunit vaccines viral
fusion proteins
are inherently unstable and by
definition
readily undergo a transition between the
pre-fusion
and the post-fusion states in order to
accomplish virus
entry and the initiation of the viral
life cycle
this inherent instability makes them
very difficult
to harness and use as subunit vaccines
the two proteins i'll be speaking about
today are the rsv fusion protein
and the influenza aj protein which both
of which suffer from conformational
instability
in the form that we would like to
present to the immune system
before we enter the field considerable
progress was made
by the vaccine research center
specifically in the labs
of peter quan and barney graham
together with jason mcclellan they were
able to accomplish a significant
stabilization
of the pre-fusion state of the rsvf
protein
this was accomplished through point
mutation and the engineering of an
additional disulfide bond into the
molecule
this enabled the identification of the
determination of the crystal structures
of these molecules and it was shown
that many of the neutralizing epitopes
or the most potently neutralizing
epitopes
are present only in the pre-fusion state
and become
lost on the transition to post-fusion
this stabilization also enabled
vaccination studies
and they were able to show roughly a
ten-fold increase
in mean neutralization titus upon
vaccination of non-human primates
with a molecule that maintains this
pre-fusion
state
so we sought to collaborate with the
inventors of this molecule which is
called
ds cap1 in order to introduce digesting
bonds
into a similar background in order to
generate a more potent and stable
molecule
as it would have manufacturing
advantages and also potentially more
potency
the influenza hemoglutinin molecule also
also suffers from conformational
instability
when the approach is taken to present
a headless aj molecule or a stock domain
only in the absence of the globular head
this approach is taken because the
globular head domain contains the major
antigenic sites for the molecule
and upon infection the immune system
targets this region generating
neutralizing antibodies
however these antibodies are often
strain specific
due to the process of antigenic drift
where the head in fact mutates over time
which causes the
vaccine to be updated on a yearly basis
so the idea of a headless h8 molecule is
to present the immune system
with the less immunogenic stock domain
given that it's primarily conserved year
to year and
elimination of the head uh would allow
focusing the immune responses on the
stockton
and it's been shown that the stock
domain itself
possess presents neutralizing epitopes
of the immune system
however attempts have been made to
recombinantly splice the head domain
from the molecule and or to
proteolytically remove the head domain
after it's folded and this results in a
loss of the stock
stock confirmation
so cauldre's approach is to apply the
additional stability
that a dityracy and crosslink imparts
to both of these problems in an effort
to lock in specific confirmations
and generate the most potent pre-fusion
specific
or conformationally intact immunogen
dietary bonds are present throughout
nature
and they're they're applied and found
in areas of proteins where a great deal
of structural rigidity is required
the ditorazine bond itself is zero
length
and the curve between tyrosine side
chains so therefore they need to be
within a few angstroms of each other
for the bond to form it's a direct
carbon-carbon bond
by tyrosine bonds are present throughout
nature and
are found in the plant kingdom in the
walls of bamboo in the insect kingdom
there's a protein called resilin that is
highly viscoelastic
present in the joints of grasshoppers
and dragonflies
they're present naturally in the human
aorta which undergoes a great deal of
shear stress
and those of us that are still consuming
carbs readily eat digesting bonds
daily as they are formed during the
process of bread making
calder takes a three-step approach to
engineering and implementing ditorosine
bonds
we first use structural based analysis
to target diatyrosine bonds to specific
regions of the protein
in order to maintain either the
pre-exfusion state
or specific conformational epitopes that
are highly desirable in terms of the
generation
of neutralizing antibodies
we then perform conservative or two
tyrosine mutations
by site-directed mutagenesis we express
that protein and purify it
and then we conduct an enzymatic
reaction on the fully folded protein
in order to introduce the ditorosine
bonds into the molecule
as i mentioned because the bond is zero
length it does not distort the molecule
additionally we take advantage of the
fact that
the bonds are need to be in close
proximity
and a proper geometry and it allows a
very specific targeting
since the bond formation only occurs
between tyrosine and side chains
the diatyrosine bond in introduces
additional covalent covalent bonds
into the molecule and therefore we call
them molecular staples
which maintain specific conformations
oftentimes
preserving quaternary epitopes
because additional bonds are formed and
the molecule is stabilized
the dityrosine bond prolongs the shelf
life of the molecule
has the potential to mitigate cold chain
requirements
and we believe increases patient
exposure in vivo
and allows for a better affinity
maturation and the development
of more potent new responses
the bond is non-toxic and irreversible
even under denaturing conditions such as
reducing and denaturing sds page
gel running conditions because the
reaction is enzymatic it's a it allows
tight control of the reaction through
the addition of specific starting
and stopping reagents
as i mentioned the bond is formed on
fully folded molecules
and therefore it avoids non-specific
aggregation
or the difficulties associated with
disulfide bond engineering
where the bond forms while the molecule
is folding
so much less conformational or
structural analysis can be applied
the diotyrosine bond has specific
properties
in that it's fluorescent at specific
excitation and emission wavelength
shown on the top left here is the ph
dependence of that fluorescence
and this enables the tracking of
ditorosine bond formation
even when they are present in
intramolecular structures
and uh allows the monitoring of the
formation of bond formation
in real time the reaction is fast as on
the second
time scale as shown on the bottom left
and because the bond is irreversible it
enables analysis
of intermolecular crosslinkers by gel
shift analysis
under denaturing and reducing conditions
and this can be tracked on kumasi gels
and or western block
as shown on the top and bottom panels on
the right
so in rsv we sought to further stabilize
the pre-fusion confirmation
by introducing dityrosine bonds
at specific locations that comprise the
major
major antigenic sites of neutralizing
antibodies
against the rsvf protein we specifically
targeted site zero
at the top of the molecule shown on the
right with a dt1 bond
and the site four five interface shown
at the side of the molecule
on the right and with the dt2 button
the dt2 bond is intermolecular
and therefore formation of that bond can
be readily tracked
by this gel shift analysis under
denaturing and reducing conditions
as shown on the left before and after
crosslinking
we have further evidence that of this
bond formation by
actual direct sequencing evidence by
mass spectrometry
where we were able to detect the
covalent crosslink
between these two side chains in the dt2
bond
the dt1 bond has been harder to detect
by mass spectrometry
presumably due to inefficient
proteolysis of the protein
by structural by the structural rigidity
imparted by the bond however we have
evidence of its formation
in that we've performed amino acid
analysis which demonstrates that there
are more
than three bonds per molecule and
additionally we analytically perform
hplc size exclusion analysis
under denaturing conditions and an
inline fluorimeter is associated with
this analysis and we can demonstrate
that the monomeric protein
does in fact contain fluorescence
it should be noted that mass
spectrometry does not identify
any other non-specific dictionary bonds
in the molecule
which demonstrates that the
cross-linking reaction and the targeting
of these bonds
is highly specific
dt pref as our molecule is called
maintains the pre-fusion conformation
better than dscap1
and has improved upon its both in vitro
and in vivo stability
in vitro data is shown here where
a highly specific pre-fusion specific
antibody is used to track the loss
of the pre-fusion state over time and
storage
of the protein at four degrees
we've compared our molecule dt3f head to
head with the dscad one molecule
developed by the vaccine research center
and we can show that over this time
frame of a total of 12 weeks
the ds cav1 molecule significantly loses
its pre-fusion confirmation
especially between the three and
five-week periods whereas dt3f
maintains the prefusional integrity
over this time
this is graphically represented in this
slide
where the time frame is taken out to the
five-week time point
where the differences are readily
observable
as i mentioned we believe that the
improved stability
of the molecule translates into greater
potency
by in vivo exposure upon vaccination
and we're able to show in head-to-head
mouse immunization studies
that we achieve roughly a three-fold
increase in mean neutralization titers
upon vaccination on alum
with equivalent amounts of immunogen in
a head-to-head study between dt pre-f
and dscap1
and most interestingly we're able to
demonstrate that
the tyrosine bonding present in dt3f
improves the shelf life of the molecule
so we performed an analogous experiment
to the in vitro
analysis however after the incubation
period
we then used the protein to vaccinate
mice
and compared vaccination with the four
degrees storage
protein over a period of four weeks
to protein freshly thawed on the day of
an infection
of vaccination and therefore
we're able to compare head to head the
loss of potency or stability
and the shelf life of the molecule over
time
upon storage at four degrees
you can see in the neutral deviation
titers on the left
and the graphical representation on the
right that dt pref
maintains its conformational integrity
and potency
over this four week period of four
degrees storage
losing only six percent which is
statistically indiscriminate
over this time frame whereas the ds cav1
molecule
lost a little close to 60 percent of its
hope
we believe this will have clinical
relevance if a reconstituted lyophilized
product
is stored in refrigerators upon
vaccinating patients
we also performed some adjuvant
selection experiments
with the dtpf molecule with an aim
towards recruiting both
arms of the immune system we tested or
aimed to identify some th1
skewing adjuvant or th1 biased adjuvants
that still achieved high neutralization
tires
demonstrating an engagement of both th1
and th2 type new responses
and we were happy to find that the
attribute advanced
specifically advex sm which contains
some cpg
over the nucleotide is able to
both maintain the high neutralization
titers that we observe on
alum and also
has a th1 bias to the immune response
and this is evidenced on the left by the
mean
and total neutralization tigers whereas
the fold excess is shown on top
over dias cav1 and on the right by igg
ratio analysis
serum analysis where the levels of
igd-2a
are and igg-1 are quantified the ratio
of which
determines the bias of the immune
response
whereas a ratio over one indicates a th1
bias
and a ratio of less than one indicates a
th2 bond
you can see on the right that
formulation with advanced
does in fact accomplish a th1 bias
while maintaining these high
neutralization fighters
we further perform process developments
and now we're able to achieve a
four-fold excess
of our molecule when formulated on
advects
as compared to ds kevlar
in agreement with the th1 bias to the
immune response
we looked at cd8 t cells in response to
vaccination with the
different adjuvant and we're able to
show in fact
that the th1 bias does recruit
more cd8 t cells that are f specific
in both zero negative and zero positive
angles
demonstrating a real bias and
recruitment
of balanced responses
against generating both th1 and th2 type
responses
when the neutralization type of data is
coupled with the t cell analysis
we also tested dt pref in cotton rats
in this study uh the molecules were
formulated on
alum and we tested two different doses
of dt pref formulated on alum and cotton
rats
a two and a ten microgram dose and we're
able to show
that both doses are able to achieve
sterile lungs as shown on the left
with the challenge post-vaccination and
incubation
and considerably higher neutralization
titles are observed
against both rsva and rsv
b viruses as compared to the
positive controls in this study which is
live
rsv infection
we also perform the competition eliza
that demonstrated
that primarily pre-f specific epitopes
are targeted by the immunity
switching now to the hemoglobin molecule
as i mentioned before
the hemoglutinin contains immunodominant
epitopes
in the variable head domain that
distract from the more conserved
epitopes
present in the spot so the
immunodominant epitopes in the head
are highlighted in red here whereas the
primary stock epitope that's been
identified
is shown in green because of the head's
immune dominance
responses against the head result
in antigenic drift and mutation of the
molecule
and therefore the vaccine needs to be
updated on a yearly basis
immune responses to the stock domain
however are more
broad and cross-reactive and have the
potential
to generate a universal influenza virus
vaccine
however current attempts to remove the
head
proteolytically or recombinantly have
failed to generate a completely intact
doctor meaning and therefore have lack
potency
our approach is to target ditorazine
bonds
into the fully folded full-length
molecule
shown here on the left at the top of the
apex
of the stock domain
additionally we engineer proteolytic
cleavage sites
in the region between the globular head
and the stock domain to accomplish
proteolytic
removal of the head
these two approaches are combined into
one molecule
and the reaction is conducted so that
thy tyrosine crosslinking
is accomplished first in the fully
folded molecule
and subsequently proteolysis
occurs to remove the globular head
building
and this allows us to maintain the
conformational integrity of the stock
domain
in the absence of the head since it's
gleaned from a full length
fully folded molecule we expect it to
have potency advantages
over different other over other
approaches
with the influenza ha we've designed at
least
three by tyrosine crosslinks
shown here on the left we've targeted
the stock
apex and it's an inter-proteomer bond
meaning that preserving conformational
integrity
upon head removal we have a slightly
lower inter-proteomer bond
shown in the center and we also have an
intraproteomer bond
that we've designed on the right
all of these designs avoid the region in
green
and permit access to the primary
neutral neutralizing epitopes present on
the stall
it was much more difficult to engineer
the proteolytic cleavage site
into the molecule as the dye tyrosine
crosslinks of all three
shown previously form and and
stabilize the molecule however it was
much more difficult
to engineer the proteolytic cleavage
sites into the molecule it took several
years
and more than uh more than a hundred
construct designs
however we've now identified cleavage
sites
present at the n and c terminal
locations in the interface
in between the globular head and the
stock domain
and we've done some optimization with
the c terminal cleaner site
and we're able to accomplish near
wild-type expression
of the molecule upon slight modulation
of this
c-terminal set and that's shown by eliza
here
whereas the wild-type pr8 protein
which is the background that we generate
our headless ha molecule in
is shown in gray and represents the top
curve
shown in between red and blue
is the expression improvements that
we've made
based on the modulation of this
c-terminal cleavage
additionally we've optimized the
proteolytic cleavage reaction
and now have near quantitative cleavage
of the molecule so as i mentioned
previously uh after dt cross-linking
the protein is locked in intermolecular
crosslink
and therefore shifts into the trimeric
state
shown on the left with the inset
and after proteolytic cleavage the
molecule shown after the latter on the
right
demonstrates near quantitative
conversion
and cleavage of the globular head domain
and a shifting in size
that corresponds with the molecular
weight lost in the intervening region
between the two proteolytics
at this time we were able to show stock
antigenicity is maintained
between the crosslinked only in blue and
the crosslinking cleaved proteins
in red
we then conducted a purification process
development
and we now have a purification process
in place
that yields pure dt headless aj
and we're ready to begin our first
murine vaccination study
uh while the previous slide demonstrated
a the protein solely after crosslinking
and cleavage
this these slides represent the final
molecule
after complete purification purity is
shown on the right
where the dt headless aj band is
indicated by the arrow
and we can show that we still maintain
both stock binding integrity
and importantly we can show the complete
absence of the head
using a linear epitope antibody
py 102 which
works in western blot so therefore if
proteolytic cleavage
solely destroyed the confirmation of the
head
uh we would still pick it up with the py
102
uh antibody and we're set to begin
our mouse immunogenicity study in next
month
that brings me to the end of the talk
and i'd like to thank you for your
attention
calder biosciences team members both
past and present are shown on the left
our grant support is below that the
members of our scientific advisory board
are shown in the middle are consultants
below that
and our collaborators in universal flu
on the left and
rsv are shown on the right and we would
thank like to thank as well
everyone who contributed to this
research